free games are leaking all over the
place so let's talk about them
once again the next PlayStation Plus
Essentials lineup has seemingly leaked
early according to a post on Deal Labs
November's PlayStation Plus free games
lineup includes neo2 Lego Harry Potter
collection and Heavenly Bodies this Trio
of freebies should be available starting
November 1st and as usual all
PlayStation Plus subscribers regardless
of tier will be able to snag them though
it's worth noting even though these have
not been confirmed yet deal Labs PS plus
leaks have been very accurate neo2 is a
Yokai slashing action game from Team
ninja that combines the pinpoint
swordplay of Ninja Gaiden with the
mechanics of a Dark Souls game if you're
up for that sort of thing it's one of
the best Souls likes around both the
PlayStation 5 and Playstation 4 versions
of neo2 will be free the Lego Harry
Potter collection is not the most recent
Lego video game out there as it was
released in 2016 but it's regarded as
one of the best by reviewers and fans
alike this collection combines year one
through four and years five through
seven into one game if you're already
blasting your way through the recent
Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga it's a
good Next Step the physics-based puzzle
game Heavenly Bodies rounds out
November's selection of games it allows
players to explore a zero gravity
environment solve puzzles and collect
space goodies both the PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation 5 versions of heavenly
bodies will be available to claim and
make sure you snag October's lineup
before this new batch of games takes its
place but the puddle of free game info
doesn't stop there because Prime
Gaming's free games for November 2022
have reportedly leaked as well and
considering this leak also came from
deal Labs it seems like the list is
correct we expect for Prime gaming to
make an official announcement covering
November's lineup later this week the
standout in terms of name recognition is
obviously Fallout New Vegas the Beloved
RPG developed by obsidian entertain
payment originally released in 2010 New
Vegas improved on the gameplay systems
presented in Fallout 3 and offered a
wider Mission variety with a huge open
world and a huge collection of side
quests New Vegas was engaging even after
completing the main campaign and even
though for some it might understandably
feel dated today New Vegas is still well
worth checking out for the first time or
to revisit the ultimate edition includes
a bunch of bonus content too so you
could wind up sinking north of a hundred
hours into New Vegas WRC 9 isn't the
newest game in the rally racing
franchise but for all racing fans who
haven't played this series before it
could be a good opportunity to give it a
try WRC features authentic off-road
racing mechanics plenty of cars and
courses and numerous solo and
multiplayer game modes Indiana Jones in
the Last Crusade would be just the
latest in the growing series of classic
Lucas Arts games to be free for Amazon
Prime members originally released in
1989 this point-and-click adventure
follows story Beats from the film of the
same name while also introducing new
locales Prime gaming also almost always
gives away some lesser-known indie games
that typically have positive reviews
etherborne is an environmental puzzle
platformer last day of June is an
interactive adventure with a heartfelt
story about love Whispering Willows is a
horror puzzle game that follows Elena's
quest to find her dad and faculty 47 is
a puzzle game set within a research
facility in Antarctica in the comments
let me know which one of these free
November games you plan on playing and
we'll see you in the next one
foreign